is your name Chandler uh yes yes it is
Chandler Bing
do you know me or are you just really
good at this game Matthew Perry reveals
why he dumped Julia Roberts back in the
90s oh my gosh the actor reflects on his
relationship with Julia in his new
Memoir friends lovers and the big
terrible thing out November 1st and in
an excerpt published by the times of
London he says it all started when the
actress was considering a guest
appearance on his hit sitcom Friends
Matthew says Julia told the showrunner
she would be on the show if she could be
a part of his character Chandler's
storyline sounds like a date to me
Matthew recalls that's when he set out
to woo the a-lister quote I sent her
three dozen red roses and the card read
the only thing more exciting than the
prospect of you doing the show is that I
finally have an excuse to send you
flowers well done well things only
heated up from there with a three month
long courtship via fax quote I was so
excited that some nights I would find
myself out at some party sharing a
flirtatious exchange with an attractive
woman and cut the conversation short so
I could race home and see if a new fax
had arrived cute right well it gets
cuter because Matthew says he was
grinning like some 15 year old on his
first date
here's an idea
have you ever worn women's underwear
well yes actually but uh
they were my aunt ednas
and there were three of us in there and
by the time they filmed that Friends
episode the two were already a couple
Julia played Chandler's childhood
classmate Susie Moss my skirt you lifted
kids laughing I was Susie Underpants
till I was 18.
that was in the fourth grade how could
you still be upset about that well um
why don't you call me in 20 years and
tell me if you're still upset about this
the actress later confirmed her romance
with the TV star during a stop by The
Late Show with David Letterman are you
dating this Matthew Perry guy I am
dating this Matthew Perry guy is this
good news for Matthew Perry
but Matthew says two months later he was
single again quote dating Julia Roberts
had been too much for me I had been
constantly certain that she was going to
break up with me why would she not I was
not enough I could never be enough I was
broken bent unlovable and Matthew says
he couldn't handle the pressure of
dating someone so famous instead of
facing the inevitable Agony of losing
her I broke up with the beautiful and
Brilliant Julia Roberts but that's not
the only Coulda Woulda Shoulda he
reveals in the tell-all Matthew also
writes about his initial crush on his
friend's co-star Jennifer Aniston he
writes he was immediately taken by her
but she declined after he asked her out
hi Chandler Monica just broke my
seashell lamp Nate
I'm gonna die alone
[Music]
okay you win and while the actor says he
was still attracted to her they were
able to quote sail right past the past
and focus on the fact that we both had
gotten the best job Hollywood had to
offer
[Music]